[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHEN GOLDBERG: Hi, everybody.
Good afternoon.
I'm Chen Goldberg and here
with me is Robert Bailey,
and both of us are from
the engineering team
at Google, working on Kubernetes
project and Google Container
Engine.
We are very happy to
be here and today we'll
be talking on how to
run your production
workloads in containers.
So, containers.
Containers has taken off
because of the benefits
in develop productivity.
The ability to start from
development environment
and take the same
image to production
can be a game changer.
The ability to push changes
quickly and as many as you want
in a day can change
everything, and you can really
respond to business demand.
We have an example from
one of our customers, one
of our Google Container
Engine customers.
Porch, for example, and
they're able to deploy from
commit to production in
less than 10 minutes.
They are doing it between
30 to 50 times a day.
I'm sure many of you
already know that and find
that very appealing.
We in Google know it
for a very long time.
We've been using containers
for over 12 years now.
Everything you know, if
it's Search, or Maps,
even Google Cloud Platform,
our VMs run in containers.
We believe that
running in containers
is the best experience both
for developers, but also
from operational perspective.
Using containers and
container orchestration,
we were able to grow our fleet
10 times faster than growing
our operations team.
Now, with Kubernetes,
we would like
to-- and Google
Container Engine, we
would like to give a
Google like experience
for all of our cloud users.
So what does it mean running
at scale in production?
Right, it's very
different than before.
How do you adjust the
quality of service
to different type
of application that
have different requirements?
How do you make sure that every
service or application doesn't
hurt other applications
and vice versa?
If you really want to grow
your fleet much faster
than your upstream, you
need to automatically
monitor and remediate
applications and machines that
are failing.
Production changes everything.
And there is another truth that
is different than the way we
at Google run.
You are not running
in one place.
I'm sure all of us
would like to have start
from scratch every time we need
to choose a different platform,
right?
Stop everything, and we are
starting to write all new code.
It doesn't work like that.
Most production workloads
have some dependencies
in existing services.
Some of them are
running on premise,
in cloud, multiple cloud.
This means that you
need a stack that
can support you running your
containers everywhere you want.
We believe you need to have
the freedom to choose based
on the merit of the
underlying cloud
where you want to run
your applications.
And we want to
meet you where you
are, meaning that if you
are now running on premise,
we want to make sure that
we are able to support you
in your journey to the cloud.
So a good place to start
is with Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is an
open source project,
a container centric
infrastructure
founded by Google at 2014.
It's based on all of
our years of experience
running containers.
When we started with
Google Cloud Platform,
we thought to ourself,
should we provide
something similar to
what we have internally
to run our own
containers to our users?
The obvious answer
was yes, but the team
insisted it will be open source.
You can imagine it
was a hard to preach
to make to take something
that differentiated us,
until that day, and make it open
source, available to everybody.
So why open source?
First of all, as developers,
we all powerful open source.
We lack the credibility
knowing what inside,
how the code looks like,
knowing the developers,
having visibility
to the roadmap.
It also provides us flexibility.
So if you would like to change
things that will meet our need,
we are able to do that.
We can integrate
different types of tools.
And for us as an
engineering team,
we needed that
immediate feedback loop.
So we knew how we are
running production,
and we knew how we are
running Google applications,
but we didn't know
much about how
everybody else are doing that,
and that was really important.
So by building a community
around our open source project,
we were able to get feedback
from partners, customers,
and just individual
contributors.
And we have taken it seriously,
and we have donated Kubernetes
to the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation,
and we are also
building programs
to help users make informed
decisions with whom
they should partner
and where they
should put their workloads.
Managing a community
takes a lot of effort
and we invest a lot in that.
So as much as we invest
in the technology,
we also invest in helping
partners and users, wherever
they are, use and
leverage Kubernetes.
And I think we're doing
a good job at that.
Looking at the
Kubernetes community,
you can see a lot of names.
Some of them are speaking in
this conference, Sam from Box.
And what I like
about this community
that not only
people are adopting,
both contributors,
both vendors, and users
are contributing back.
So if Kubernetes is so amazing,
its an open source technology
and everybody can
use it, then why
do you need Google
Container Engine?
So first of all, yes,
it is still Kubernetes,
and we are very proud of that.
Kubernetes is a very good tool
to automate the deployment,
and scheduling, and management
of containerized applications.
On top of that, we are bringing
our own experience, [INAUDIBLE]
of experience to manage
your cloud still,
and we do all of that
on top of Google Cloud
Platform with the best
network, persistent disk,
amazing performance, and
such features on Google Cloud
Platform.
This provides for
you, the best platform
to manage your
applications, instead
of focusing on the machine
and the infrastructure.
And of course,
running in production
means worldwide at scale.
You can see this is
our current regions,
and of course, the
future regions.
So we keep expanding the reach
of Google Cloud Platform.
So how can I convince
you that this is ready
and the technology is ready to
run your production workloads?
I think the best way to do it
is just to use by real customer
examples.
Niantic was a big story for us.
Very exciting last year.
They chose Google
Container Engine
for its ability to
orchestrate their containers
cluster at planetary scale.
What was interesting
about it, when
they thought about
planetary scale
when they planned
everything, they
missed was actually
planetary scale is.
And we can see what they thought
will be target traffic, what
they planned for.
So they planned five
times worse than that,
and then we can see what
was the actual traffic.
And for us, this was also
amazing because something
that you get when you are a
Google Container Engine user,
you get us as part of your team.
And I think this is
one of the biggest
value when you are working
on Google Cloud Platform.
You get Google as your SRE.
SRE stands for Sire
Reliability engineers.
Today, when we manage
our production systems,
we have dedicated teams that
are responsible for managing
those production application for
Google and for our customers.
And this is not about monitoring
and recovering your system,
its about continuously
improving the production,
creating more tools, more
monitoring solutions, more
automation to make sure that
everything is working better
all the time.
And when you are a Google
Container Engine user,
you benefit from that.
So going back to the
Niantic story, when
they saw the traffic is much
better than what they expected,
we just get the team together.
We had people from support,
from Niantic of course,
SRE and engineering team working
together and making sure that
players can continue and
play and find Pokemon's.
So what do you get when you
start a cluster on Google
Container Engine?
The first thing we'll do--
so it takes about every three
minutes, and we will
provision your cluster,
and you will get a control
plan, which we will
manage for you on your behalf.
And from a user perspective, you
get a black box API endpoint,
and we take control
of all of that.
But the main benefit is
not about the provisioning
of the cluster, but the way that
we manage everything for you.
So we make sure the
control plan is up to date
and we upgrade to the
latest Kubernetes version.
We monitor it, we make
sure it's available,
we make sure we have backups,
we make backups are working.
That's something that
sometimes we forget to do.
And we also provision your
VMs, but when we do that,
we'd not just take the
standard Kubernetes version,
but we also add some
add-ons that are required
to run production workloads.
If for example, you need an L7
load balancer or [INAUDIBLE]
for monitoring on
your dashboard,
we make sure that
everything is available
and you can immediately start
deploying your application,
instead of worrying for
cluster configuration.
I'm also happy to
announce that we just
expanded our
responsibility, and now we
are not just responsible
for your control plane,
we also do VM auto
repair and auto upgrade.
This means that we
update Kubernetes
to the latest version, we
monitor automatic repair.
It's now available on beta
and I encourage you all
to opt in to those features.
This means that you get
all the innovation coming
from Kubernetes, which if its
new features or security fixes,
all in a reliable manner.
Now, let me hand
over to Robert and he
will talk about auto scaling.
ROBERT BAILEY: Thanks then.
So one common problem that
application developers face
is how to handle
traffic fluctuation.
Some applications have a sort
of predictable diurnal cycle
of traffic, while
other applications,
such as the one by
Groupby, have large spikes
during holiday
seasons when you might
see a lot of people
purchasing on Black Friday
or leading up to Christmas.
As an application
developer, you should not
need to worry about constantly
tuning your application.
Google Container Engine
can take care of that
and scale the number
of VMs in your cluster
and the number of pods that
are serving your application.
So first a bit of background.
I just mentioned pods.
What is a pod?
Some of you are probably
very familiar Kubernetes,
for others this may be
something new for you.
A pod is a small
group of containers.
It's not a one to one
mapping with containers,
it's one or more containers,
and this is actually
a very important
distinction because there
are a lot of times when you want
to build an application where
two things need to work
very closely together.
A pod is also the atomic
unit of scheduling
when you want to
schedule your application
to run in your cluster,
it gets scheduled
with pods being co-located.
Pods share an IP address.
They share local disk.
They share local IPC.
And so, a good
example of this is
if you wanted to launch
a simple web server.
You might have a
custom application that
knows how to pull your
website content from GitHub,
or from a Cloud Storage bucket,
or from a local on-prem version
control system,
and you pair that
with an off the
shelf generic web
server like Apache or NGINX.
By putting these two
containers together,
you are then able to deploy
them as a single unit
where the data puller
can write the local disk
and the web server can
serve off the local disk.
The great thing about
this is that it decouples
the application
development lifecycle
for the two pieces of code.
You can push new versions
of the web server
if there's a security
fix, without having
to rebuild your
application, and vice versa.
You can update your
application without having
to rebuild the web server.
So now imagine you're
running your small websites
and it starts to get popular.
So you could, quite
easily with Kubernetes,
scale the number of replicas,
the number of copies
of your website
that are running.
You could start out with
one, go to two, go to four,
and easily handle
the traffic load.
But you probably don't want
to spend all of your time
constantly changing the number
of replicas of your websites
that are running.
That sounds kind of boring.
You want to spend time
building new websites.
So what you can do is you can
turn on horizontal pod auto
scaling, which will monitor
the incoming requests
load and the utilization
of your pods,
and automatically scale
the number of pods for you.
It will actually also scale down
if the traffic to your website
goes down as well.
So you're not actually
using extra resources.
So this is great.
So the number of pods
keeps increasing,
but now let's say your
website gets really popular
and the number of VMs that
you have in your cluster
is no longer sufficient to
run all of the replicas you
need for your site.
You can also enable a
cluster auto scaler,
and a cluster auto scaler will
look at the unschedulable pods
that you've requested--
you or automation
has requested to
run in your cluster,
and will provision new VMs for
you to allow those pods to run.
And it's actually
smart enough, if you
have a cluster with
different types
and shapes of VMs to
provision the right type of VM
for your pod to
run, because it runs
a simulation of if I
add a new machine type,
will the pod actually run?
And it doesn't add
VMs needlessly.
It won't actually help
you scale your cluster up.
Like horizontal
pod auto scaling,
it will scale your cluster
down when the extra VMs
are no longer needed.
So if you have a big traffic
spike, say for the holidays,
and then traffic goes back
to sort of a normal level
after the holiday
event is over, you
don't have to go and deprovision
VMs to save yourself money.
The cluster auto scaler will
do that for you automatically.
One of the great things about
working on both Dual Container
Engine and Kubernetes is
that we often find cases
where we can solve a problem
for our Google Container Engine
users, and also for
the community at large.
The cluster auto scaler
is a great example of this
because we recognized that
this was a problem that we
had for our paying Google
Container Engine users,
but it was also a
problem for anyone
who wanted to run Kubernetes.
So in this case, what we
did is instead of writing
a proprietary cluster auto
scaler that would only
work with Google
Container Engine,
we actually wrote the
cluster auto scalar as a pod
that you can run in any
Kubernetes deployment.
So it runs just
like any other pod
and it talks to the
computer's API to figure out
when it should scale up.
And our implementation then uses
GCEs API to actually scale up
their cluster, but the
core logic is reusable
and you can plug it
into any other system
to scale a cluster
elsewhere, and we
think that this is a great model
for how we can enable people
to run on Google
Container engine,
but feel like they
have the ability
to run their cluster
anywhere else as well.
So running Kubernetes
in production
often means you have
multiple teams that
needs different levels of
access to your cluster.
It also means running
development testing staging
environments, so you can
validate your co-changes
before you push
them to production.
In a Google
Container Engine, you
can levers of power of Google
IEM and Kubernetes namespaces
to make sure that the right
people have the right access
to your cluster.
So Kubernetes namespaces
divide your cluster up
into logical
sub-domains, and each
of these logical sub-domains
has different levels of access
control, has its
own DNS hierarchy,
so you can easily
segregate services,
and you can use namespaces
for whatever you'd like.
You can create a namespace for
every user in your department.
You can create a
namespace for every app
that you deploy and
you can use namespaces
for different environments.
So you can have a testing
namespace and a staging
namespace.
They're quite
flexible and it allows
you to easily segregate
different parts
of your application.
One thing that we do recommend
is using a separate cluster
for your production instances
because although namespaces
are a great logical boundary,
they are not a very firm
boundary in terms of
isolation, either for security
or for interpod utilization.
And with Kubernetes
1.6 coming out soon,
you can use roll
base access controls
to find IEM roles to permission
inside of a namespace, which
allows you to create very
fine grained controls of who
can access resources
within different namespaces
in a single cluster.
So at Google, we're really proud
of the load balancing products
that we offer as part
of the cloud platform.
Our load balancing is built
on the same front end serving
infrastructure that powers
services with billions
of users like Google
Search, Google Maps, Gmail,
and YouTube.
With Google Container
Engine, your application
can also take advantage of
these amazing capabilities,
just like Niantic did when
they were building Pokemon GO.
Google Container Engine offers
two levels of load balancing.
The first is level
four load balancing.
Level four load
balancing is appropriate
if you need to terminate
TCP connections
or if you need to
handle raw UDP packets.
Level four load balancing
sends your traffic
to what we call a service.
A service in
Kubernetes is a group
of pods that provide a stable
IP, and one thing you'll
know if you want to run
containers that can get
rescheduled, is that
containers can move around
inside your cluster.
And so by using a
service, you know
that your traffic will
always get to your pods,
even if those pods had been
relocated onto new VMs.
External services are then
exposed with an IP address.
By default, services are
internal and not exposed
to the internet, but it's
quite easy to expose them.
And on Google
Container Engine, this
is done with the cloud
network load balancer.
The other type of service that
we use is called an L7 service.
So many applications
that are built today
are built on top of
the web foundational
standards of HTTP and HTTPS.
We have an objective
in Kubernetes
called an ingress
object, that makes
it very easy for you to
configure this L7 load
balancer.
And the power of
the L7 load balancer
is that with a single exposed
IP address and port or domain
name, you can easily map
traffic to multiple services
in your cluster.
So you could map some traffic
to a static content service that
is surveying static web pages
that have been pre-generated,
and you can map other
parts of your URL paths
to dynamic content if you
need to talk to a database.
And all this can be expressed
within an object that is then
declaratively applied
to your cluster,
and then instantiated in terms
of a Google Cloud L7 load
balancer.
And with that, we're going
to switch over and do
a quick demo.
Excellent.
So for this demo, I've
pre-provisioned two clusters
in two different regions.
So there's one cluster that's
in the us-west1 region and one
cluster that's in the
europe-west1 region.
And what I'm going to
show you is how easy it
is to deploy an application
onto Google Container Engine,
and get it up and running,
and serving real traffic
to end users.
So the first thing
that we are going to do
is this application is going
to use a Cloud Spanner, which
is a newly announced part
of Google Compute Engine.
And Cloud Spanner
is a global database
that has strong support
for transactions.
It turns out, to talk
to Cloud Spanner,
the identity model requires
you to use a service account.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to create something called
a secret in Kubernetes, that
encapsulates the client side
credentials of that service
account to allow us
access to Cloud Spanner.
Now, I haven't mentioned
secrets yet, but what secrets do
is that secrets de-couple
the sensitive information
of your application, such as
passwords or private keys,
from the actual configuration
of your application.
And this is great
because the configuration
of an application, you generally
want to put in source control,
especially if you're
running a production
because that makes it
easier for you to version
and to share among
multiple people.
But you really don't want
to check your passwords
into source control.
I know we've probably
all seen people
will do a search of GitHub and
find all sorts of passwords
on GitHub, which is not
really a best practice.
So secrets allow you to separate
those two pieces of data.
So the next thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
create a deployment.
A deployment is a
higher level controller
that creates pods for you.
Generally, you don't
want to create pods
by yourself because a pod
has a limited lifetime.
If a pod dies, it
will not be recreated,
but if you create a higher level
controller like a deployment,
the deployment is then
responsible for making sure
that the pod is always running.
So in this case, we've
created a deployment
with a single replica,
which is going
to launch a single pod for us.
And in the deployment
specification
there are lots of
different fields.
Most of them are not
actually very important.
This one is pretty important.
This tells us which container
we're actually going to run.
This deployment has
a single container.
And then this container
is parametrised
by a few environment variables.
So through the
environment, we're
going to tell it
where to connect to,
like which Spanner database
instance since we're
going to connect to.
And then we're also
going to tell it
where to get the credentials
to connect to that database.
So we just created a secret.
That secret is
automatically mounted
by Kubernetes inside of
the pod at this location,
and then the code will read
the secret from that location
and connect to Spanner.
Caps lock.
There we go.
So, if we then look at
our pods in the cluster,
we'll see that we
have a single pod
and it's now in
the running state.
So while we were
inspecting the ML file,
the scheduler took that
deployment, turned it
into pods, found a
place to run the pod,
and the system then fetched
that container image
from Google Container
Registry, instantiated it,
and now it's running.
So that's great.
So next what we're into is
we're going to create a service.
So in this case, the
service that we're creating
is a service with an
external load balancer.
What this external load balancer
will do, as I explained before,
is it will actually talk
to the Google Cloud APIs
and create a load balancer
for you that will expose
your service to the internet.
If you leave this
last line off, you
will create a service that
is only accessible inside
of your cluster.
If we list services, you can
see that the Kubernetes service
is the default service.
It's provided with your
cluster, and the service
we just created its called Next.
The external IP takes about
a minute or so to show up,
and once that IP
shows up we'll be
able to go ahead and look
at that service in the web
browser, and see, and
load our web page.
So while we're
waiting for that, we
will go back and look at our
networking tab in the cloud
console.
And if we look at load
balancing, we should see,
here's our service.
So our service is now being
provisioned by the system.
This is done
automatically for you.
You tell Kubernetes I'd
like a service externalized,
it goes ahead and
programs that for you.
And there it goes.
So now we have an
external IP address.
So we'll go ahead and load that.
Aha, there we go.
Great.
So our pod is serving
a simple web page.
It tells us the name of the pod.
So we can actually go
back and verify gt1t5.
Great.
Looks like it's matched up,
and it's telling us the region
that it's running in.
Now, our plot is pretty simple.
It serves this data, but it also
writes an event into Spanner.
And so if we go into
the cloud console,
we can actually load up Spanner
and we can find the database
that we provisioned,
and we can actually
search in the database.
And say OK, look,
we've got requests.
They're all coming
in to us-west1.
OK, that's great.
So we've got our service.
It's been pushed
into one cluster.
It's externally exposed.
If you guys want, you can
hit the same IP address
and you'll get the
same response back.
Each of those responses is
now being written to Spanner.
So of the most powerful
things about Kubernetes
is the way we've deployed
this application.
It's very easy, but it's
also very easy to do it
again, and again, and again.
And so in this example,
we have two clusters
in two different
regions of the world.
And we can apply
exactly the same yaml
files to our second cluster and
get exactly the same results.
We can get the
same code running,
and since it's
been parametrised,
it will now tell us that
it's running in Europe.
So to do this, what
we're going to do
is we're going to
switch contexts.
So the Kubernetes client
command line interface
knows how to talk
to a single cluster,
but it has credentials to
talk to multiple clusters.
And using contexts,
you can actually
switch between
different clusters
that are all being configured.
You can pass it onto command
line for each command you run,
or in this case, we're going
to set the global context
so we don't have to pass it
for each of the commands.
The three commands
I'm copying now
are exactly the three commands
that were previously run.
They're just running them now
in a different environment.
So again, if we
get deployments, we
see that there's the same
name of the deployment.
If we actually list the
nodes in our cluster,
we can now see that we are
indeed talking to the Europe
cluster, and we're
no longer talking
to the us-west1 cluster.
And if we try to
get services again,
we'll see that it's pending.
If we run a query here again--
so all of our access--
it looks like we had a couple
that went to europe-west1.
That's probably from
when I was testing
prior to the presentation.
I forgot to clear
out the database.
That's still pending.
So we'll give that just
a second to come up.
We can check on
our load balancer
again and watch it
get created, here.
So on this page, we've got
the single load balancer that
was there before, and shortly
we will get a second load
balancer.
OK, there it's coming up.
So quite shortly here we
should have another IP address.
And there it is.
Excellent.
And when we load
this IP address,
instead of saying
us-west1, it should tell us
now we're running in Europe.
And again, it's telling us
the name of the pod that
is hosting this application.
So we can, if we want to
scale our replicas out,
and we can see the
pod name change.
So now we see that
we've requested
there to be two replicas,
and if we reload the page,
we should see it
flip between the two.
It may take a second
for that to show up.
So now we have our
service and it's
been deployed into two different
regions, which is great.
We can serve European
customers from Europe.
We can serve US customers
from the US if we'd like.
By pointing them to two
different IP addresses,
we can map to domain names.
But most people want to
have sort of a single entry
point for all of
their customers,
and one easy way to do that
is you can create a DNS entry,
and you could put both of these
IP addresses in the DNS entry.
That will cause traffic to
round robin between the two
clusters, which is
perfectly reasonable,
but we think a much
better solution
is to use Google's Global
Cloud L7 Load Balancer.
The L7 load balancer
will automatically
push traffic to the two
clusters based on where
the request is coming from.
So for this demo, I've
pre-provisioned an L7 load
balancer.
You can see it's configured
to point to the two clusters,
one in europe-west1,
and one in us-west1,
and you can actually see that in
both cases, all of the backends
are healthy.
So the backends here
are the VMs, the nodes
that are part of the cluster.
And then if we go
look at the traffic,
you can see that it turns
out we're sending traffic
to both of these backends.
So before the
presentation started,
I started a while loop--
I should do that more slowly--
with a curl command.
So I set up a DNS entry that
points to my L7 IP address,
and just 10 times a second I'm
curling that from my laptop.
And my laptop's on the
West Coast of the US,
and so the majority
of the responses
here are going to
be us-west1, if you
watch this line as it toggles.
But I set the L7
load balancer so
that after getting five
requests per second to the US,
it'll actually spill
over traffic to Europe.
So what this means is that if
too many requests are coming
in, they will overload
my set of backends,
they'll spill over to
the second cluster.
And you can see from
the terminal output
here, that every
once in a while we
are getting responses that
are spilling over to Europe.
Likewise, if we load
the L7 IP address here,
for the most part,
we will get us-west,
but every once in a
while we'll get Europe
because the traffic
is spilling over.
So this is great.
So now we've deployed
our application.
We've deployed it
in multiple regions.
We're serving traffic globally.
What happens if
something goes wrong?
So in this case,
we've got requests
coming in from
both places and so
we're going to switch back
to the us-west cluster
by changing our
context, and we're
going to delete our service.
So this is simulating
what happens
if something goes wrong.
Now your service
no longer exists.
Your service is no longer
exposed to the internet.
If you go to the
first IP address,
it was trying to serve us-west1,
it's not going to work anymore.
Right, so that service
IP address is gone.
So if you'd set up DNS, you'd
have two IP addresses that
were being round robined,
and about half the time,
your customers would
stop getting responses.
And even worse, with
DNS propagation delays,
if you want to
change the DNS entry,
it's going to take quite a while
before that change gets out
to all of your customers
and they actually
see the new IP address
that they should
be going to that's in Europe.
But if we look at
the L7 balancer,
it has automatically
failed all of our traffic
over to the cluster
that is healthy,
and all the responses now
are coming from Europe.
And you can see
now, that they're
bouncing back and forth
between the two different pods
that we've scaled up to.
And there's a little bit of
lag in the cloud console,
but if we refresh
this in a second,
we'll see that all of the
traffic is now overflowing,
and it does mark here that all
of our backends are unhealthy.
And with that, I think we're
to switch back to the slides.
So the final area that I'm
going to talk about today
is portability.
As I mentioned
earlier, we recognize
that not everyone has the luxury
of running their application
in Google's Cloud.
One of the primary
tenants of Kubernetes
is that we should
have portability
across deployment environments.
Kubernetes should run
great in Google's Cloud,
it should run great on
premise, it should run great
on different operating
systems and different hardware
architectures.
Anywhere you can
run containers, you
should be able to run
Kubernetes to manage
those containers for you.
Now, it's really easy for
someone to stand up on stage
and tell you these
platitudes about how easy it
should be to run
Kubernetes anywhere,
but what we want to
do is sort of show
you through examples
of customers.
And so, Poki is a
company who decided
to rebuild their monolithic
application using
micro services and
containers, and they
chose to use Kubernetes
for their container-centric
infrastructure.
They launched Kubernetes in
their existing environment.
They ran it themselves
for a little while
and then they decided
it's a lot of work
to keep up with updates.
It's a lot of work to
manage my own cluster.
We're going to try out
Google Container Engine.
And so they switched to
Now we have a happy
customer, but in the process
of migrating into Google
Container Engine, because all
of their applications were
written to run on Kubernetes,
it gave them the
confidence that if they
do want to run anywhere
else, as long as they
can run Kubernetes, they are
free to go wherever they like.
So today they're happy customer,
but if they get dissatisfied,
then they are free to
run it on GCE itself,
without using Google Container
engine or, on bare metal,
or anywhere else they'd like.
And the reason
that this works is
because Kubernetes
provides really good
extensibility points.
Kubernetes can scale
down all the way
to running on your laptop if
you want to run a development
environment.
Again, we would not recommend
that for production.
But it's great for testing
out your applications
before you push
them to production.
That means you can
run your containers
while you're on an airplane
without having access
to the internet.
You can also run
it on bare metal.
You can run it in many
different cloud environments.
And the API implementation
Kubernetes is completely open.
The whole system is
modular and you can
replace different components.
And the way that we
support different clouds
is that we do replace
different opponents.
So earlier in the
presentation and in the demo,
we showed how we can integrate
with Google's networking,
Google's cloud load balancer,
Google's L7 Load Balancer.
When you're integrating
with those systems,
you're expressing the
intent of your application
through Kubernetes
objects, through services,
and through Ingress objects.
And on GCE, on Google
Container Engine,
we then instantiate those
objects through Google's APIs.
But if you're running
elsewhere, you
can run a different
Ingress controller that
might instantiate your L7
load balancer using NGINX
Or you might instantiate a
service controller just using
IP tables.
So the whole system is
modular, and replaceable,
and can run anywhere.
And the other nice
thing about this
is it your applications
are not written
to depend on any
particular infrastructure.
Your applications depend
upon the Kubernetes APIs
and Kubernetes mediates those
APIs with the environment
that they're running in.
So we talked about
the network models.
Another good example
of this is volumes.
So if you're running
on Google's cloud,
you're most likely
using Google's PDs,
Google's persistent
disks, which can be
mounted into your containers.
But if you're running
on bare metal,
you might instead have
persistent volumes
that are backed by NFS.
And this allows you to easily
migrate your application
from the legacy deployments
into containers,
and lift and shift
onto the cloud
when you're ready to migrate.
It further means that
after that migration,
as we saw with Poki, that you
don't feel stuck where you went
to, that you still
have the flexibility
to go wherever you think is the
best place for your company.
So we like to say this
puts your apps on wheels
and lets you roll it around,
wherever you'd like to go.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it back to Chen.
CHEN GOLDBERG:
Thank you, Robert.
So we've seen that production
changes everything, right?
And we talked through
some of customer example
how we, in Google, can help.
And I forgot to mention,
maybe it's a nice story
to tell now about Niantic.
They started on
Kubernetes 1.3 and they
had a specific size of cluster,
and they need to scale it up.
At the same time,
we were releasing
a new version of Kubernetes
that was supporting
2000 VMs per cluster.
So without disturbing anything,
and for us doing all the work
for that, we were able to scale
them out to a bigger cluster.
So we first upgraded a cluster,
the control plane, and then
they were able to grow
to the scale they needed.
We saw auto scaling.
We talked about access
control, and load balancing,
and of course, portability.
We want to believe
that you have a choice
and we want to keep
you that choice
and have the freedom
to make a decision.
We commit to be the best, OK?
And this is our
goal, to make sure
that this is the
best place for you
to run your containerized
applications.
But all I speak about
is about today, right?
And again, as I
said, when we are
making a decision about where
to run our production workloads,
we want to make sure
that we can be confident
that this is the right platform
and the right decision for us
for the future.
I really like this
quote from Sam
because it's able to
capture in one quote, both
the today and the future.
And the first thing he
mentions is about Kubernetes
and why Kubernetes is production
ready today and the future.
I think one thing to note
is about the community.
The community has been
growing very fast.
It's one of the top 10 projects
in Git-Hub from engagement,
and looking on the
1500 contributors--
I think more interesting even
to say that out of those 43,000
commits, more than 50%
of them are actually
not done by Googlers.
This means that the pace of
innovation is mind blowing.
OK, the new features,
the new requirements
are really there to make
sure that everywhere you
take Kubernetes and
run your containers,
you will have a
production ready system.
I also believe that this
really raises the bar.
When we speak about
when to release
a new version of Kubernetes,
we look at all environments,
and we are making sure that
it works well everywhere,
and we have users
and contributors
that are doing the same.
What we say, for example,
if you are planning to grow
and you want to now have
a higher new professional
people to manage your cluster.
When you choose Google
Container Engine,
it's the same as
any other Kubernetes
deployment from that
knowledge perspective.
So having 200 meet-ups
around the world
allows you to hire those
professional to join the team,
without the need to train them
specifically to your system.
And the last thing is that
having that modularity,
by having different projects
based on Kubernetes,
you can change your
monitoring solution.
We talked a lot about
the infrastructure,
but also the tooling around it.
Your DevOps tool
chain, you're logging,
your monitoring,
tracing, all those things
can be changed with new
things that will come along.
So to summarize, Google
Container Engine benefits
is first of all, pure
upstream Kubernetes.
This is the fastest way
to get the Kubernetes
releases available to
you in a reliable manner.
We bring our 12
years of experience
of managing production
systems on containers to you
by managing and upgrading
your cluster, your control
plan, and your VMs.
And you get all the benefits
and all the goodness
of the Google Cloud platform.
You can really focus on
your application deployment.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]